in this short video we'll be talking
about the HPT Axis or the hypothalamus
pituitary thyroid axis this is a
neuroendocrine control system which
modulates our body's response towards
metabolism and stress
obviously this axis includes the
hypothalamus pituitary and the thyroid
gland
so from the hypothalamus trh hormone
gets secreted and secreted into the
hypophicial portal system ultimately it
lead to the release of TSH hormone from
the pituitary the thyroid stimulating
hormone acts on the thyroid gland
and lit and leads to the release of T3
and T4
then the T3 and T4 level can rise in the
blood when it goes beyond a level it
leads to a negative feedback into the
pituitary and at the level of
hypothalamus so this is the entire axis
but let us try to understand why this is
at all important why this kind of
negative feedback and modulation is
important
thyroid gland and thyroid hormones are
implicated in several biological
processes
first of all they regulate metabolism
they regulate blood cell production
thyroid control metabolism of protein
carbohydrate and fats almost all aspects
of metabolism is modulated by thyroid
hormones
overall electrolyte balance and
electrolyte absorbance is also mediated
and modulated by thyroid hormones lastly
thyroid gland can also secrete hormones
such as
thyrocalcitonin which regulates blood
calcium level so already you can see
there are so many physiological roles
that this gland plays so obviously the
output of these gland has to be
regulated very precisely
and this tuning is really important
because when this tuning goes off
there are conditions like hypothyroidism
or hyperthyroidism so too much is bad
too little is bad and each of these
conditions lead to several problems
so let us try to understand how this
regulation happens so in the
hypothalamus there are specific cell
types so there are parvo nuclear neurons
in the paraventricular nucleus of the
hypothalamus which secretes the trh
overall the trh gets secreted into the
portal system and reach the anterior
pituitary in the anterior pituitary
there are so many different type of
cells like thyroid drops corticotrops
somatotrophs electrodrops gonadotrops
and many more
but the thyroid drops are the key cell
on which the trh hormone works and this
is the cell type that produce TSH
so trh stimulates the production of TSH
from the anterior pituitary
okay once TSH is produced it would bind
to the TSH receptors on the thyroid
follicular cells
so it gets secreted into the blood and
reach the thyroid gland
the TSH hormone is a glycoprotein with
two subunits Alpha and beta
for Simplicity they are shown as dots
anyway what really happens when TSH
binds to the TSH receptor many things
happen one of the most important event
is upregulation of the iodine
transporter it allows lot of iodine to
get inside the thyroid follicle and
reach the colloid eventually this iodine
would be the iodine ion would be
converted into the molecular form with
the help of thyroperoxidase enzyme
meanwhile there are specific
thyroglobulin proteins
which are getting synthesized in the ER
eventually they would move through the
Golgi and eventually get secreted into
the colloid and this is the substrate
for thyroid hormone production
so the thyroid peroxide is made iodine
and these iodination would take place in
these thyroglobulin molecule there could
be monoidotyrosine dihydrotosine there
could be even combination of these which
is creating triidothyronine and
thyroxine the T4 so all this thing is
happening inside the thyroid follicle
after that these hormones would be taken
back by pinocytosis by the thyroid
follicular cell eventually these
hormones would be
released and secreted into the
bloodstream in the bloodstream there are
several carriers which can take these
hormones in their place but now we
understand how the thyroid follicle or
as a thyroid gland how it is producing
the TSH the thyroid hormones the T3 and
the T4
now this particular axis has to be
regulated
because there could be negative feedback
on pituitary and hypothalamus if
everything goes okay
then this situation is known as
euthyroidism that means a normal
functioning of this particular axis so
there is proper negative feedback all
the level of T3 and T4 is in a balanced
fashion so it's not too much or not too
little
but things can go wrong anytime such as
in primary hypothyroidism in that case
what happens is low level of thyroid
hormone gets secreted
so and this particular regulatory
feedback loop is hindered why because
there could be let's say thyroid surgery
that reduce the thyroid gland's ability
to produce thyroid hormones also there
could be autoimmune thyroidities like
Hashimoto's
also there could be secondary
hypothyroidism there could be a feedback
error from the pituitary
let's say pituitary is not secreting
enough TSH
that could be also another possibility
and it happens in anterior pituitary
failure or in many cases of two tumors
in the pituitary gland
there could be the other uh situation as
well like primary hyperthyroidism and
secondary hyperthyroidism in both these
cases too much of thyroid hormones are
produced maybe let's say in a primary
hypothyroidism like in Graves disease
there are too much of T3 and T4 in the
blood which lead to several problems
also in secondary hypothyroidism what
happens is there are tumors in the
pituitary so it leads to Too Much
production of the TSH that leads to a
lot of thyroid hormone production from
the gland but all these things lead to
hyperthyroidism and Associated problems
so overall these kind of clinical
situation tells us a precise balance of
thyroid hormone in the blood is really
essential for our body's normal
physiology
so I hope this was useful if you like
this video give it a good thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
you can subscribe you can support our
Channel via super thanks
see you in next video